so if you're going to hurt someone what
you think essentially is okay what would
really hurt me and then you think well
I'll just do that to them it's like
that's that's that's a that's a good
theory it's very sophisticated so
anyways so okay so what happens Adam and
Eve wake up they weren't supposed to do
this God told them that they are gonna
be sorry if they did that but they did
it anyways because that's what people
are like and because we always learn
things that that knock us out of our
present paradises right we're curious
and we won't leave things alone and
maybe things are not so bad and then you
you know ask some questions that maybe
you're not so happy about asking once
you find the answer and you fall out of
your little paradise into history and
you got to work to set things right
again and anyways God gets wind of this
and and he chases Adam and Eve out of
the Garden of Eden but he says some
interesting things when he chases them
out he says all right now you know
what's the consequence of that and he
says to Adam you're gonna have to work
now that's cool that's really cool well
he is God after all you know also he he
knows what he's talking about
he says you're gonna have to work so why
would you have to work now that you knew
you were vulnerable well the answer that
is well if you know you're vulnerable
that stretches out into the future you
know you're going to die you know that
you're fragile it's like maybe all your
problems are solved right now you're all
sitting here you're safe you're not
hungry you don't want anything to drink
it cetera but what about tomorrow what
about next week or next month or 10
years from now it's like just because
you got all your problems solved for
this second doesn't mean you've got them
solved for the rest of your iterations
through time so you got to work and the
work is the sacrifice of the present for
the future and so that's exactly right
you have to work now you think see
what's interesting about that this is
the theory that I was going in it of
course God tells that Eve well you've
really you know screwed things up too
you're gonna have these big brain babies
and and that's a big problem you're
gonna suffer in childbirth and then
they're going to be dependent on you
forever and because of
you're gonna be dependent on this man
that you just woke up and that's not
gonna be very pleasant for either of you
but tough luck and so that's it that's
the curse in some sense and it's exactly
right but the thing is there's a theory
in there there's an interesting theory
of suffering that's implicit in that
story and the theory of suffering is
that suffering is built into this
structure of self-conscious being it's
built right into the structure so if
you're a self-conscious being that's
your lot it isn't someone else's fault
it isn't a consequence of sociological
oppression
it isn't that a consequence of the fact
that our society isn't organized
properly it's just part of being alright
so that's a big deal because that's a
that's an important theory because one
of the questions is well well you know
why is there suffering what are you
gonna do about it and it's a big it's a
lot different if it's just the way it is
for you and if it's actually your fault
that he's suffering those are or maybe
it's the group's fault that you're
suffering those are major those theories
are really really different than in the
second story and Cain and Abel
Cain makes sacrifices to try to get it
in good with God and Abel make
sacrifices and the sacrifices are kind
of archaic from our perspective they're
burnt offerings so the smoke goes up
where God can detect it because he's up
there somewhere up there where the stars
are and God rejects Cain sacrifices and
we don't really know why but it kind of
looks like Cain is the second Raider and
then God came goes and complains to God
and says like what kind of stupid
universe did you make here I'm breaking
myself in half trying to get things
together making the proper sacrifices
and nothing's going well for me and Abel
well you know he's everything he touches
turns to gold everyone loves him he's
even a really good guy it's like so
annoying what's up with this place you
built and God tells Cain don't be coming
and telling me that the entire fabric of
reality is wrong because it isn't
working out for you says sin crouches at
your door like a like a sexually aroused
predatory cat that's basically the meta
or that that God uses and he says that
you let it in and had it and let it have
its way with you and that's really an
interesting way of putting it because
what God says to Cain is that you know
you're all bitter and resentful and
really it's no wonder because you know
things aren't going well for you and
then you've got Abel who's over shining
you in every way and but yeah it's your
fault this terrible thing waited at the
door and you let it in and then you
entered into a creative union with it
and you produced something as a
consequence and that's this tormented
spirit that you have now and it's
polluting your relationship with reality
and that's why things aren't working so
very well for you so go put yourself
together before you come and tell me
just exactly what's wrong with the
structure of reality and Cain isn't very
happy about that because really is that
really what you want to hear that's
right like you have more misery than is
necessary because you really didn't put
your act together and you know it and
you've done it creatively and so Caden
goes and kills Abel that's the story of
how resentment enters the world and it's
the first story in the judeo-christian
canon let's say about actual human
beings because Adam and Eve were made by
God so they don't really count Cain and
Abel were born and so that's something
so there's a reaction to suffering right
the necessity of sacrifice and the
consequence of the necessity of
sacrifice is that some sacrifices work
and others don't and then if your
sacrifices aren't met with the with the
good will of God let's say well then
that makes you angry well of course it
does you can take God out of the story
if you want if you're not happy with
that kind of mythological or narrative
statement but it doesn't really matter
because the whole point is is that if
you make sacrifices especially if
there's second-rate things aren't gonna
go very well for you and you're gonna
get bitter and resentful and murderous
and maybe genocide 'el and it's really
interesting you know because Cain has
descendents and if you bug if you
transgress against them they don't just
kill you they kill seven of you and then
his later descendants kill
nine of you there's this exponential
growth of murderous nests as a
consequence of Kane's primary primal
fratricide and then the next story is
the flood and that's not an accident
there's nothing in those stories is an
accident okay so now you've got two
different theories about the nature of
suffering you've got the one I just laid
out it's called the foundational story
of suffering and malevolence and you
have the Marxist story which is well
there's oppressed people and the reason
they're oppressed and suffering is
because the oppressors are oppressing
them those are not the same theories
right and there's a utopianism that's
implicit in Marxism which is if you
could just get the damn oppressors to
stop oppressing the oppressed then the
Utopia would arrive and so not only are
the oppressors responsible for the
suffering of the poor they're also
responsible for the fact that the Utopia
isn't here for everyone and so how
reprehensible can you get well then that
certainly justifies that degree of
malevolence justifies pretty much
anything you'd like to do to them